[Music]
foreign
you are watching The Press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the columnist
and broadcaster Steve Richards and the
former conservative special advisor
Salma Shah they'll be with us from now
until just before midnight so let's see
what's on some of those front pages for
you now
well the financial times leads with the
prime minister's insistence that the
government's offer of a pay increase
between five and seven percent for
public sector workers is final
the guardian however says that very
statement has angered the leaders of the
health unions
and with Junior doctors on a long strike
from today the telegraph says they too
are now Under Pressure to give up their
action and accept what's on offer
and that issue the mail has a this blunt
headline will doctors now end their
callous strikes
the eye says a million workers will
benefit but that the books will be
balanced by Cuts in government
Department budgets rather the new
borrowing
the express meanwhile says fees paid by
migrants when they come to the UK will
also go towards funding the increases
the mirror sums it up like this pay
relief but Cuts pain
another story footballer dele alli's
Revelation that he was sexually abused
at the age of six and that he's just
come out of weeks of rehab for sleeping
pill addiction that's the top story for
the Metro
and the star has a story about climate
change and its effects on bees
and a reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we aren't joined tonight by Steve
Edwards and uh Salma Shah welcome to you
both one in person and uh one remotely
here we're mixing it up tonight and
we're going to start with the mail and
um this headline will doctors now end
their callous strikes uh this is the
male dubbing them callus isn't it Thelma
yes it is and you can uh sort of expect
where the newspapers are going to go in
terms of their titles as to what
position they're going to take on the
strikes and the male has been very
strident with this big front page on um
doctors continuing and Junior doctors
certainly saying that they're going to
continue with the strikes while teachers
and the teaching unions have responded
positively saying that they would ask
their members to end the wave of
classroom strikes and this is obviously
off the back of the fact that they seem
like they're going to get what they uh
want or at least some of what they want
from the prime minister so hopefully
there'll be some kind of end to this
um to this stage this to the government
and Steve the male choosing to to call
them them callus the strikes by Junior
doctors this does put added pressure on
them as well as that from from Rishi
sunak saying you know no matter how many
more strikes go ahead the the offer
isn't going to change
yeah this is a fascinating story on so
many levels and the broader context is
here is a country with anemic economic
growth with governments either
ideologically or too scared to put up
taxes so how do you pay for uh pay
demands at a time of stubborn inflation
um and Rishi sunak has sort of found a
way today of doing it in that he claims
it's going to come from existing budgets
um but the reaction has been very
diverse teachers are called off their
strikes uh some in the NHS still are
Furious and plan to go ahead but all
sides are having to adapt to this
situation where without economic growth
without higher tax revenues
there isn't going to be the money
um if a government's not going to borrow
for it
um and so it's unsurprising in a way
that the uh tensions of recent months
are not fully resolved with a click of a
finger from Rishi sunak today
yes and you mentioned there how it's
it's all going to be paid for in the
espresso we're offered one of the uh the
the solutions that the government's
looking at and that's increasing fees
paid by migrants these are um Visa fees
and and suggesting that there will be
significant rises in those huh yeah and
what's interesting about this which uh
is not quite obvious to most people is
that we actually have one of the most
expensive visa fee systems in the world
um and it was all part of the hostile
environment under Theresa May's
leadership of the home office so it'll
be interesting to see what happens down
the line in terms of fights between
departments about where that money is
actually going to end up so whilst you
can say that some of this is going to be
paid by Visa fees we actually don't know
how much that is and where it ends up
going and whether it will be towards pay
increases or indeed preventing schools
from having to take the pain of the pay
increases which is what this is designed
to do and Steve from what you've read
um the the sources that will fund these
pay Rises do they seem sufficient to
meet the demand
emphasically not this whole thing about
where the money's coming from reminds me
of the sort of uh tax and spend debate
that labor politicians are always asked
in the build up to an election so what
if you do this though there'll be a
black hole we were going to put Tempe
here and 5p there they're scrambling
around ministers trying to find ways of
showing that this is going to be paid
for without wholly knowing how it's
going to be done these are big uh
increases in terms of a departmental
budget to find cost cutting and the
examples we've got so far will kind of
it's not at all clear how much revenue
will come from these alleged savings
um but they're easy ones to put forward
as examples on day one the reality is uh
services will be impacted
um in any uh sort of overall cuts to pay
for this pay Rise
um and and they won't say that today but
that's the reality and do you agree with
with Salma that we likely more likely to
see
um many internal tussles over uh budgets
and what cuts might have to be made
yeah I mean and in a build up to an
election uh I think in the in in the end
they'll basket somehow in other words
they will not impose painful Cuts but
they will sort of in theory have to if
they're going to pay for it from
existing departmental budgets I think
money will materialize somehow or other
um without the opposition of tangible
painful Cuts I I heard a school's
Minister say oh no there won't be any
impact on classrooms and so on well
where's the money going to come from the
things always asked of Rachel Reeves and
others from the labor side
um and they'll find it somehow or other
um but I doubt if there will be painful
tangible Cuts in the build-up to an
election
similar to the ft and as I was saying
before wish you soon at because um well
they're describing it as he's thrown
down the gauntlet to trained unions by
announcing pay Rises for public sector
workers between five and seven percent
um insisting no amount of strikes will
change his final offer this is it
according to the Prime Minister yes and
I think that there is a lot of store to
put by that because it's not least
because
uh he wants an end to strikes but so
much of what he wants to deliver is
based on the ending of these strikes so
if if we go back to his five priorities
from the beginning of the year one of
them is very much based on uh waiting
times and hospitals so in order to get
that moving again he really needs uh
doctors and nurses to get back to work
and get it to be as productive as
possible I also think that there is
another interesting bit of the ft and
that is about that fiscal discipline
piece in advance of a general election
so as Steve as rightly said you know
labor politicians are always going to be
asked where is the money going to come
from and people are very resistant to
the idea of borrowing for wage increases
and so you've got here hunt promises no
extra borrowings at the same time he's
trying to manage these two things the
fiscal discipline and trying to meet one
of his key five pledges so the Prime
Minister insisting that the offer is
final in the guardian we read that
unions are Furious Steve
yeah and so uh on we uh go he's got to
say it's final but he has got to get the
health unions back to work for the
reason Selma argued there was
speculation that he was opposed to uh
giving in to these uh pay review uh
recommendations but he had to because he
has to get these people back to work in
order to have any hope of meeting one of
his so-called five priorities of
reducing uh waiting lists he also has to
say this is a final offer given he was
indicating before that he might not go
this far so he can't say look you know
just hold on a second you'll get more
from us
um but the kind of tension between
Health unions regarding this as
inadequate and saying doctors are going
to go off to other countries where they
pay more which incidentally is an issue
um that's not going to go away uh with
today's uh announcement
and Salma the mirror suggesting or
predicting that the um the cash
coming from existing budgets will mean
that they will inevitably be cuts to
Services yeah I mean and that's just uh
without doubt or you've got high
inflation real terms finding new budgets
it's going to mean cuts and so we go
back to the point of there's going to be
arguments there are going to be tensions
and there are going to be a whole host
of bad stories that are going to come
out as a result of cuts to services
Steve they use the phrase robbing Peter
to pay Paul
well yeah but as I say in a pre-election
year the amount of robbing that goes on
internally is pretty limited I I think
you know they are being tough they are
proclaiming fiscal Prudence fiscal
conservatism within the context of
accepting the pay review propositions
um but I wonder whether there will be
painful Cuts in the build up to the
election I think it'll all be pushed
beyond the election
summer let's just quick look finally at
the eye and questions about whether the
government's approach is that the
correct one to handling the public pay
sector
um dispute and actually not wanting to
to borrow more money or they're going
about it the right way I mean they're
not they don't have a lot of options and
they don't have a lot of room to
maneuver and I think what's interesting
here is that the eye says that UK public
debt is on calls to hit and I watering
310 of GDP by the 2070s and so you know
pushing that message forward is
certainly at the Forefront of the Prime
Minister and the Chancellor's mind at
the moment are they handling it well
there's a lot of mixed messages going on
you know are they going to accept the
pay review are they not and so we
finally have this out I think they could
be a lot better about the communications
and the messaging we shall see whether
they have handled it uh well uh
resulting in whether the strikes that
continue or not Selma and Steve Ball at
the moment thank you we are going to
take a break coming up it's understood
the BBC whilst preparing its own
investigation in Tiffany redwood's
conduct before the allegations about him
came to light we'll be discussing that
next do stay with us
[Music]
welcome back you are watching The Press
preview still with me uh Steve Richards
and Salma sharp so let's have a look at
this story in the Telegraph and we read
that the BBC was investigating
allegations about Hugh Edward's conduct
before the sauna published its story
this is uh the latest to come out yeah
and what's interesting is that you know
you've already mentioned that Tim Davey
the director general of the BBC is going
to be up against a parliamentary up in
front of a parliamentary committee next
week
um and this is clearly going to form
part of their questioning and so you
know one of the questions that sort of
jumps out of me from this story is how
was the handling been and from my
perspective it's not been great because
on one side you have the editorial now
that we understand has been
investigating Hugh Edwards and on the
other side you've got the corporation
and the corporate side of the BBC as
presumably defending Hugh Edwards behind
the scenes before his name came forward
so I think there's going to have to be
some serious unpacking and and how the
BBC has actually handled this and what
their processes and protocols have been
around this instance
Steve
yeah I mean I've covered a lot of
so-called BBC crises and Salma and I
both worked at the BBC and I remember
one of the other big crises I won't go
into any of the details asking one of
the managers so who for me to get a
sense of who's running the BBC response
to this crisis who who should I speak to
and they said well it's all a bit
complicated and I knew there would be
trouble ahead and it's always hard to
kind of find where the lines of
responsibility and accountability are
often at the BBC and that's part of the
problem but what I would say also is is
this that um yes it's interesting that
the BBC News side we're investigating
Hugh Edwards but over precisely what
what form were these texts if it's
flirtatious texts it wouldn't have been
the first person in a newsroom to do
that I'm not saying there isn't a human
interest story here clearly there is
um but still weighing up its significant
is difficult until we know more about it
okay summer let's look at this story
finally in the guardian and that is that
the UK's response to a threat from China
is inadequate what do we know so this is
interesting because this is a comment
that's coming from
um the intelligence and security
committee which actually receives
um secret intelligence in private closed
sessions so the fact that they're saying
this is not only intriguing but actually
quite worrying because they have talked
about Chinese straight estate
institutions active aggressively
targeting the UK and that without Swift
and decisive action we could end up in a
nightmarish scenario and this is what
I'm quoting from that represents not
just a commercial challenge but an
existential threat to Liberal Democratic
systems and even though it's got a it's
on the front page it's quite small and
this definitely needs I think a lot of
teasing and a lot of scrutiny because
this is a very very important
parliamentary committee Steve worrying
they're talking about a whole of state
assault by the Chinese government
it's so sweeping and extensive the
degree in which they suggest almost a
takeover could take place on a whole
range of different areas and it's been
so fascinating this government which has
in effect been in a power for 13 years
have had so many different approaches to
China and I still don't think it's
resolved from Cameron and Osborne being
very keen Boris Johnson actually very
keen to to form quite a close trading
relationship was stopped by his party
and now we have a committee report like
this which suggests
um that it's almost kind of too late
um and so mastering what to do about
this increasingly economic and defense
superpower is one of the great
challenges and and it there has been no
coherence in the last 13 years